[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
enfin
[Musique]
un canapé
[Applaudissements]
j'ai rencontré le capitaine paul watson
à paris en 2005
et ce jour-là a changé ma vie parce que
pour la première fois j'ai entendu un
discours qui connaît exactement à ma
vision du monde et surtout il y avait
les actes qui suivait donc j'ai été voir
paul et je lui ai dit que j'avais envie
d'embarquer avec lui et ce qu'il fallait
que je fasse pour ça il m'a posé une
question très simple composent
aujourd'hui encore dans les formulaires
de candidature pour rejoindre sea
shepherd
c est ce que tu es prête à risquer ta
vie pour une baleine moi j'avais jamais
vu de baleine de ma vie mais je
connaissais la réponse et quelques mois
plus tard j'étais sur un bateau de sea
shepherd pour aller en antarctique sur
ma première mission et c'est dans ce
contexte là dans le sanctuaire baleinier
antarctique que j'ai vu mes premières
baleines
j'ai vu leur souffle au loin avec toute
l'émotion que ça peut que ça peut
provoquer surtout dans ce contexte
particulier on savait qu'elle était en
train de fuir des braconniers puisque le
sanctuaire baleinier antarctique au bout
du bout du monde c'est quand même
violées chaque année par la flotte
baleinière japonaise est malheureusement
sea shepherd est la seule entité
présente sur place pour empêcher les
massacres pendant plus de 12 ans c'est
ce qu'on a fait et lors de cette
première mission j'ai compris
concrètement ce que ça voulait dire
risqué sa vie pour une baleine le
lendemain de noël on a eu un cadeau qui
était assez extraordinaire c'est qu'on a
réussi à trouver le navire usine nisshin
maru qui est un navire qui fait 8000
tonnes soit 10 fois plus gros que notre
bateau à nous et ce jour là c'était un
jour de tempête avec des creux de plus
de huit mètres de haut et est ce bateau
fonçait droit sur nous paul watson et en
étant paul watson nous a dit on ne bouge
pas on va lui barrer la route donc très
clairement on était sur un vieux bateau
qui avait 50 ans d'âge qui aurait coulé
à pic
si on avait été percutée comme on était
loin et très isolée de tout on pouvait
compter sur le secours de personne et
quand le premier officier est venu le
dire tous en combi de sauvetage
collision dans deux minutes là je me
suis servi de signer les pétitions c'est
quand même plus simple
et dans le même temps pas une seconde
j'ai eu envie d'être ailleurs que
précisément là où j'étais je trouvais ça
hallucinant finalement que 45 bénévoles
issus de 23 pays différents avec des
profils très différents mais tous animés
par la passion et l'envié de changer les
choses soient finalement la seule force
d'interposition contre la troisième
puissance économique mondiale
bon si je suis là pour vous raconter ça
c'est que le capitaine du nisshin maru a
viré de bord à la dernière minute nous
ce qu'on a réussi à faire
finalement c'est lui faire passer ce
message c'est que quand on dit qu'on est
prêt à risquer nos vies pour des
baleines ce n'est pas un slogan c'est
une réalité et on a eu l'occasion de
leur le leur démontrer plusieurs fois
ensuite ce qui est intéressant c'est que
en fait quand j'ai rejoint sea shepherd
sur cette première mission ce que
j'appréhendais le plus finalement
c'était même pas de passé deux mois dans
les mers les plus dangereuses du monde
d'être opposé à une flotte de
braconniers qui était beaucoup plus
puissante que nous non non ce qui ce qui
m'inquiétait c'était qu'on allait être
vegan pendant deux mois moi à l'époque
je manger de la viande et du poisson
même si aussi loin que je m'en souvienne
j'ai toujours adoré les animaux j'avais
pas forcément fait cette connexion à la
fois éthique sur le fait qu'on massacre
70 milliards d'animaux par an pour se
nourrir et puis en même temps sur la
question environnementale qui est que la
consommation de viande et de poisson est
la première cause de réchauffement
climatique
première cause de pollution des nappes
phréatiques première cause de zones
mortes dans l'océan première cause de
déforestations première cause de
pollution de l'eau et une importante
cause aussi de faim dans le monde
c'est avec sea shepherd que j'ai
découvert tout ça mais j'ai surtout
découvert cet univers culinaire vegan
dont je n'avais pas idée et on avait une
chef cuistot à l'époque qui est toujours
là d'ailleurs très inventive et qui nous
faisaient des soirées à thème donc on
avait la soirée indienne italienne
japonaise et je me souviens que sur la
soirée italienne je me suis dit ok des
pizzas sans viande donc ça va encore
mais des pizzas sans fromage
ça va être compliqué quand même et
pourtant elle nous a servi je me
souviens très bien cette pizza
végétalienne toutes plus bonnes les unes
que les autres je peux vous dire qu'en
antarctique on ne peut pas se permettre
d'avoir des carences quand on travaille
12 heures par jour sur le pont à des
températures proches de zéro donc voilà
il était possible de manger bien bon et
variés et ça c'est quelque chose qui du
coup qui m'a servi par la suite et qui
nous a servi notamment dans d'autres
campagnes notamment aux îles féroé qui
est en fait un archipel volcanique
rattachés rattaché au danemark un peu en
dessous de l'islande
les îles féroé se livrent chaque année à
un massacre de dauphins globicéphales
qu'on appelle le green d'un drap
donc c'est environ 1500 dauphin qui sont
massacrés chaque année leur argument
c'est la tradition et ce qu'ils nous ont
dit que c'est que bon ben nous on mange
des dauphins vous mangez bien des
poulets des vaches des cochons donc donc
c'est vrai que c'était pratique à ce
niveau là au niveau de la cohérence de
leur expliquer que en fait non on en
mangeait pas mais justement les et féroé
comme l'antarctique
c'est des paradis terrestre qu'on arrive
à transformer en enfer
cette mission-là aux iles féroé en 2014
notamment ggf et fabriqué en fait des
petits bateaux en aluminium qu'on a
envoyés là bas avec une équipe et
l'objectif était très simple c'était de
patrouiller dans l'archipel il ya 23 b
de chasse et il fallait trouver les
dauphins avant que les féringiens les
trous et les rabattre vers le large
c'est des enfants qui sont très faciles
à driver c'est d'ailleurs ce qui est ce
qui cause leurs pertes malheureusement
puisque quand ils les trouvent les
rabattre vers db2 chasse et y tue les
groupes entiers donc plusieurs
générations à la fois n'y a jamais de
survivants et ce jour là en particulier
il s'est passé le pire qui pouvait se
passer c'est à dire qu'un groupe de
dauphins 80 dauphins étaient venus se
réfugier à l'intérieur d'un fjord parce
qu'il y avait une tempête et il y avait
beaucoup de petits avec eux donc en
général c'est ce qu'ils font et dans ce
fjord la bête chasse en fait était trop
petite pour tuer le groupe
donc les féringiens avait prévu
d'attendre le lendemain une accalmie
météo pour ensuite driver les dauphins
dans une dans une baie voisine
donc on était face à un dilemme est ce
qu ont bravé la tempête avec des petits
bateaux qui font
six mètres de long et on essaye de
sauver ses dauphins ou est ce que on
prend pas le risque et on laisse faire
on a envoyé les bateaux ils sont arrivés
dans le fjord et ils ont escorté les
dauphins vers la pleine mer et ce jour
là les féringiens se sont sentis
humiliés qui sont très fiers de leurs
ils sont très fiers de leurs capacités
de marin c'est des descendants de viking
donc pour eux ça a été ça a été en échec
cuisant
je suis passé à la radio quelques jours
après pour leur expliquer que pour nous
il s'agissait pas d'une victoire contre
eux mais d'une victoire pour la vie et
simplement
on était suffisamment passionné on a eu
plus envie de sauver ses dauphins qui
n'ont eu envie de les tuer et c'est ce
qui a fait la différence
donc aujourd'hui on est en 2017 et à
l'heure actuelle on tue encore
volontairement des baleines des dauphins
qui sont des animaux charismatique avec
un capital sympathie extraordinaires
donc quand on pense à ça on se dit qu'il
va être compliqué de réussir à sauver
les requins qui ont cette image de
mangeur d'hommes
à tort ou de sauver des thons ou des
crevettes dont tout le monde se fiche
éperdument
et pourtant quand les gens nous
demandent finalement si les baleines
disparaît c'est très bien c'est triste
mais qu'est-ce que ça va changer à ma
vie c'est simple en fait si les baleines
disparaissent non seulement on aura
désenchanté le monde
mais si les baleines disparaissent on ne
sauvera pas l'océan parce que si on ne
sauve pas les baleines on se rend à rien
d'autre et un monde où le snj ans est
mort c'est un monde sans nous donc si on
ne sauve pas les baleines on ne se
sauvera pas nous même ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre
on est dans un rapport à l'océan et
surtout à la vie marine qui est un
rapport d'exploitation et notamment sur
ce qui est des poissons qu'on ne
considère même pas comme des animaux
dont on se réfère en termes de tonnes en
termes de stocks alors qu'avant d'être
des protéines dans l'assiette de
n'importe qui les poissons la vie marine
en général sont d'abord des individus
des ouvriers essentiel de la machinerie
océans qui n'est ni plus ni moins que la
première machine de régulation du climat
est la première source d'oxygène puisque
il ya plus d'une inspiration sur deux
que je prends quand je vous parle que je
dois à la vie marine donc
ça nous amène à l'urgence de la
situation les nations unies prédisent un
effondrement des pêcheries commerciales
d'ici à 2040 8 donc c'est demain est ce
que ça veut dire concrètement c'est pas
seulement qu' il y aura plus de choix de
poisson au restaurant ou dans les
poissonneries
ça veut dire c'est la mort de l'océan
donc c'est techniquement la fin de la
civilisation humaine
et pourtant les médias sont très loin de
relayer sa avec l'importance que ça
mériterait puisque un exemple
emblématique par exemple qui est celui
du thon rouge
le thon rouge a atteint des niveaux de
population catastrophique notamment en
2010 et en 2011
il ya deux ans une femelle thon rouge a
été vendu 1,2 million de dollars sur le
marché japonais à tokyo
et quand les médias en parlent il en
parle comme d'un record de vitesse comme
si c'était quelque chose
d'extraordinaire mais presque de positif
et pourtant c'est un signal d'alarmé
dramatique parce que un poisson qui
attend ce prix là c'est un poisson qui
est presque condamné
donc on est loin de prendre la mesure de
l'enjeu et il va falloir qu'on aille
très très vite
et le problème c'est que on est dans une
course contre la montre et dans le même
temps quand on regarde le temps que
prend la prise de conscience et surtout
le temps de d'évolution des mentalités
et surtout d habitude on a tendance à se
dire que c'est peut-être une cause
perdue et pourtant comme le dit paul
watson
les causes perdues sont peut-être celles
qui valent le plus qu'on se batte pour
elle et nous quand on regarde dans le
rétroviseur de sea shepherd qui a fêté
ses 40 ans cette année
on voit des millions de vies sauvées on
voit beaucoup de batailles gagnées mais
pour ce qui est de la guerre pour sauver
l'océan
je sais pas je sais pas si on va la
gagner mais pour moi l'essentiel c'est
en tout cas pour ne pas avoir de regrets
pour être en paix c'est de se dire qu'on
aura tout fait pour l'océan m'a appris
l'humilité face à lui je me suis senti
tout petit et c'est ce qui m'a le plus
fait grandir et sea shepherd m'a appris
que la vie n'est jamais aussi forte que
quand on a trouvé une raison pour
laquelle on est prêt à risquer
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]